وزير الداخليه السعوديه الامير عبد العزيز
بن سعود بن نايف ان منسوبي مكافحه
المخدرات يحظون بدعم كامل من الامير محمد
بن سلمان مشيرا الى ان الحمله الحاليه
لمكافحه المخدرات مستمره حتى تحقيق كل
اهدافها
ودعم كل الاجهزه الامنيه بكل المكنات
والامكانات من اجل تحقيق الاهداف اعتقد ان
احنا نشاهد اليوم
ما في شك العمل استباقي مهم التحضير قبل
اي عمليه مهم ارجو نقل تحياتي لكافه
الزملاء العاملين في الميدان وكذلك جهودهم
مقدره جهودهم مرموسه ما زلنا في بدايه
الحمله مستمره الى ان تحقق ان شاء الله كل
اهدافها من البلاغات تعامل بكل سريه وبكل
احترافيه بحيث لا يلحق المبلغ اي مسائله
ونحافظ على سريه بياناته وعلى معلوماته
فما في شكل للاستفاده من المعلومه ومهم
مكافحه المخدرات ورجال مكافحه المخدرات
يحظون بدعم كامل من سمو سيدي ولي العهد
مثل ما سبق ان ذكرتكم الجهود اللي
شاهدناها في الايام القليله الماضيه منهم
زملائه في القطاعات الامنيه
جهود مميزه وان شاء الله نحقق كل اهداف ان
شاء الله المرجوه بدعم وتوجيهات ومتابعه
وللعهد اللي في الحقيقه يتابعوا الجهود
بشكل لحظي
والحمد لله الامور ماشيه في الطريق الصحيح
وان شاء الله تكلل كل الجهود بالنجاح
من ضم الينا من الرياض مدير البرامج
العلاجيه في مركز رشد التخصصي للارشاد
الاسري والنفسي وعلاج الادمان حمد الشحات
حياك الله استاذ حمد
في كل المنازل اليوم الحديث الاول هو حمله
مكافحه المخدرات في الشوارع تجد ترى مظاهر
مختلفه تماما نحن امام حمله هي اشباب
الحرب ربما اذا جاز لنا وصفها بهذا
التعبير على المخدرات ترتيبات قرارات
صلاحيات واجراءات غير مسبوقه ابدا كمتابع
انت او متخصص في هذا اول شيء كيف شايف
نتائجها حتى الان والحمله كما قال سمو
وزير الداخليه قبل قليل لا زالت في
بدايتها
الحمد لله نسمع الخبر من لا زالت في
بدايتها الموضوع يحتاج وقت اثار الحمله
الان الحمد لله يعني قبال على العلاج اصبح
مضاعف يعني الاعداد عندنا طباعه اكثر من
ضعفين في الاقبال على طلب الحلول من خلال
العلاج انا بعطيكم معلومه حلوه مره يعني
اول مره تطلع بالاعلام وبتكون يعني
العربيه يعني حصريا في هذه المعلومه كان
الاقبال من الشباب على الشابات على العلاج
يمثل 10% من يعني عدد المراجعين اليوم
تجاوزنا 60% يعني
العلاج تجاوزوا 60% ولله الحمد كيف تتم
العمليه هذه
تتم العمليه نستقبل العميل نفتح له ملف
بعدين نحوله على غرفه الفحص مبدئي التقي
بحالته ومعرفه مناسبه العميل للبرنامج
وبعدين يدخل على متابع رئيسي يبدا معه في
دراسه الحاله لعمل خطه علاجيه مناسبه اكثر
الحالات او انواع الادمان في المخدرات
الان مادتين منتجره يعني بشكل يعني
يعني ملحوظ اللي هي ماده الشبو وماده
الملكه اللي هي الجبل
اللي هي تستخدم لبعض العلاجات الدوائيه
يساعد استخدامها في محظوره مقيده من اكثر
من سنه
فهذه المادتين هي الاكثر الان في السوق
يعني في التعاقب نتكلم عن نسبه معينه انت
من خلال متابعتك
في مقابل مثلا الحشيش الحبوب وغيرها من
الامور
هم الان اقبلوا بسبب الحمله المباركه
الشباب نفسه يعني هذه الحمله اليوم مقارنه
بالحملات السابقه ليش نتوقع منها نتائج
مختلفه والى متى ممكن تستمر ترى مثلا انت
كبير في هذا المجال وشو الهدف النهائي لها
وهل يمكن تحقيقه
الهدف النهائي لها هو مثل ملك العارف
تنظيف البلد من السموم هذه من الاجرام
اللي صاير من التعاطي من الالم من الهم
والوهم اللي يعيش يا غالبيه شبابنا انت
اذا بغيت تدمر الشعب تدمر شبابه واليوم
شبابنا قاعد يتدمر بالمخدرات والدوله
رعاها الله وحفظها التفتت للموضوع التفاته
حازمه والتفاته يعني صراحه تضرب باليوم
الدوله بيد من حديد على اي انسان تسوي له
نفسه انه يتلاعب او يعني يخدش قوه يعني
هالبلد واللي يقصد بالقوه اللي هي شباب
البلد الشابات البلد الله يحفظ الجميع
اليوم اذا شباب نتدمر تدمر البلد بالكامل
والحمد لله عندنا عندنا قياده شابه واعيه
الله يعطيهم العافيه على هال الحمله
المباركه شكرا لك مدير البرامج العلاجيه
في مركز رشد التخصصي للارشاد الاسري
والنفسي وعلاج الاد مان حماه الشيحان
وتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات